now we have some breaking news just
coming in the predominantly conservative
u.s supreme court is officially rolling
back the landmark decision granting and
protecting abortion rights in the united
states the ruling known as roe versus
wade has been under attack ever since it
was enacted 50 years ago now this
decision is highly controversial in the
u.s with feelings running high on both
sides the greatest division falls along
political lines and along religion
with republicans and evangelical
christians overwhelmingly against
it and we are going to cross now to our
dw washington bureau chief who is
following the story of the supreme court
rolling back this landmark decision
on abortion in us this decision may not
come as a surprise but what exactly does
this mean for women in the u.s now
it's not coming as a surprise but you
can really feel the
shock waves going through washington
right now
with this ruling it basically means that
the protection
of the right to get in a poor abortion
nice and nationwide uh why it is taken
away you know i think it's important for
our international audience to understand
it's not the case that abortion is not
allowed anymore in the united states but
this 50 year old protection
of the right to get an abortion is taken
away and it's now up to the
states to decide whether women are
allowed to get an abortion and how long
into their pregnancy they get an
abortion if there are
exemptions for example
for rape or incest so
yes this is uh really a very very uh
important day today as this 50 year old
uh
right this 50 year old protection is
taken away
it's obviously an issue that is
intensely political emotions running
very high some for some against what
kind of reaction could this potentially
trigger in the broader uh population
well it is interesting you know the
latest polls say that the majority of
the americans are for
abortion rates so the supreme court with
three appointees from
president donald trump
is obviously basically not following
the wishes of the majority
of the americans we shall see i mean
there are already 26
states which plan to ban or restrict
abortion access they have all the
the the kind of the legal writing in the
books and then there are six teens who
have already uh laws out there which
probably will
come into effect within the next couple
of days so i'm sure that we will see a
lot of protests going on up at the
supreme court we will be there
soon and also report live from the scene
there but there will be also marches and
protests
along the united states on the one side
but then on the other side you have
those who are in favor
of this ruling they will applaud the
supreme court for making this decision
dw's in this pool in washington dc thank
you so much
now as we were just hearing today's
decision overturning roe versus wade
gives states the ability to make their
own laws and many conservative states
have already indicated that they will
severely restrict access to abortion for
conservative lawmakers it's the
culmination of a decades-long fight
against the decision that legalized
abortion nationwide
the supreme court's ruling on roe versus
wade was a landmark decision effectively
legalizing abortion across the united
states
the case focused on jane roe in reality
norma mccorvey a texas woman seeking an
abortion since state law only allowed it
in cases where the mother's life was in
danger she was denied
her case was picked up by civil rights
lawyers looking to challenge
anti-abortion laws
in january 1973 the justices ruled seven
to two that a woman's right to privacy
superseded a state's right to ban
abortion
the decision set off a fierce legal
battle which has become increasingly
partisan
after row the republicans added an
anti-abortion stance to their platform
an effort to enlist support from the
religious right
during the trump presidency a major
victory for republicans looking to tilt
the balance of the supreme court
in just four years he was able to
appoint three justices giving the court
a 6-3 conservative majority
during their senate hearings each
appointee was asked about roe and each
said they would follow precedent
in may a leaked draft opinion suggested
the supreme court planned to overturn
roe
justice samuel alito called it
egregiously wrong from the start
in post row america 26 out of 50 states
are expected to quickly ban or severely
restrict abortion
that's galvanizing democrats who still
want to keep abortion legal a position
recent polls suggest is supported by
some 60 percent of americans